[Music]
let's start off this hour with landon in
memphis hi landon how are you
how's it going dave i appreciate you
taking a call sure what's up
so i'm 24 or 25 and my wife is 24 we're
in baby step 7 and we're looking to
upgrade here
uh at a house that we have potentially
to buy it's 275 the house come in right
now is about 2 30.
um and so i have the cash obviously to
upgrade and we obviously paying cash but
i'm wanting to know if it'd be stupid to
upgrade or if i should just sit around
and be patient and the reason we wanted
to buy it is because it's a friend of
ours and they just weren't going to put
it on the market where we didn't have to
deal with the competitiveness of it and
it would just be a clean you know
purchase without having to deal with
other offers and stuff
um but my only really hang up is is the
area isn't really the nicest area in the
world it's not it's not bad but like the
house directly across is an older
gentleman and he doesn't really keep up
with his property really well like i
mean the graph might get away with him
and there might be you know just kind of
things all over the yard but you know i
just afraid that if i want to resell it
that that might hurt me potentially or
you know i don't know what do you think
what do you
make about 180. you're killing it dude
freaking 24 years old with a paid for
house and asking questions like this
you're stud well done i appreciate you
appreciate it well done man it's amazing
beautiful
um well a couple things just pop into my
head just listening to your story i mean
there's nothing wrong with anything
you're saying
um
i it doesn't sound like much of an
upgrade
well it would be significantly more of
an upgrade honestly um the house right
now would probably wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait i mean you're
talking about forty thousand dollars oh
no no no yeah so i'm talking about an
upgrade in house i know but i mean how
are you getting so much more house for
only 40 grand more
well the reason is because my buddy
that's selling it to me the flipper and
he's gonna give us a pretty substantial
discount on it would go for about 325 on
the market
and it would be about 800 more square
feet and it's significantly nicer
is really what i'm saying the only
downside is the goob across the street
well you know the area in general isn't
the nicest so i mean one street over
half a million dollar houses and then
you know it's this street and probably
in the 250s the
um but you know what you said three and
a quarter i thought you said you're
gonna get three and a quarter
oh yes sir i mean it would but i'm
talking about the last time these were
sold
you know two three four five years ago
oh that's not nice
you know what we're asking is what's
worth today
you're saying it's a 350 000 street
today and the house is one block over a
half million
right
i mean i'm not seeing a lot of minuses
in this situation that's pretty
incredible for this market to be able to
have that kind of deal that's that
sounds incredible what is your
hesitation right now aside from the area
aside from the neighbor do you have any
other things holding you back
yeah so it would just be spending the
amount of money cash right now you know
like i don't know should i just be
patient and pile up cash or you know
because i mean we are saying oh you're a
tight one you don't want to let go of
the money dave dave i am a penny pincher
yeah now i know how you got here okay
yeah and it's killing you to spend your
little bank account that's what it is
i can't really emotionally what's your
wife say about this deal
she's the same exact way she loves the
house not too happy about the area and
you know but she's okay bye five years
from today are you gonna be glad you
bought it
i would say yes
not just financially but also in living
there and living in that specific house
i think we would be i think we would be
you're not gonna be whining about the
neighborhood five years from now no i
don't think we would be and you know
another main reason we wanted to sell it
because we badly want to get out of what
we're in now okay most neighborhoods are
something most neighborhoods are getting
better or getting worse there isn't very
few neighborhoods that are staying
exactly the same five years from today
five years from today do you think this
one will be better or worse no it will
be better it's a very trending town okay
quit being a tight wide and by the house
soon
you haven't done anything impulsive
since you were 12.
that's true
[Laughter]
i understand i understand i know you and
i and i appreciate that about you
because it's what got you to where you
are and it's actually but like with most
of us our greatest strength can be our
greatest weakness
and in this case you're getting
paralysis of the analysis because you
get a joy from holding on to that money
so the resale doesn't make you afraid in
any way if the guy you told me the
neighborhood was getting better
it is then i ain't worried about the old
man across the street he's going to die
and his heirs are going to sell the
place
right right okay i'm just afraid that if
i wanted to resell it in five to seven
years that somebody would tone away
because of what the neighbor's house
looked like if it's one neighbor and the
rest of the neighborhood's getting
better i'm not worried about that and
whenever you go to sell maybe you can
ask him if you can mow his lawn just
take a day and fix it up for him
yeah yeah we used to do that we had a
guy in the neighborhood we would all
just show up and clean up his yard you
know but that was a different world
though yeah you did that now people
shoot at you but
um yeah it's crazy that's fun though
that that's a really cool question from
a really cool young man yeah 24 years
old on baby step seven wanting to
upgrade houses and has the cash to do it
that is awesome now there's so so little
i had to correct in that call i'm just
sitting here amazed you know i mean he's
already so far ahead of the game
and uh for those of you don't know baby
step seven means he has zero debt has a
fully funded emergency fund is putting
15 percent of his income away for
retirement household income and if they
have kids he's funding but he's funding
kids college funds so that that's all
the baby baby step 7 is the last of our
steps and it's basically become very
wealthy and very generous
which by the way is always good for
tight wads to do the generosity thing
too because it helps you loosen up a
little bit
helps you enjoy your money a little bit
more yeah and i'd way rather him be a
tight wad then just freely spending and
irresponsible that's incredible just
makes him it makes him a unicorn he's
awesome he's beautiful beautiful
situation he's got his family in a i
mean they're going to be
multi-millionaires by the time they're
30 right you know at the rate he's going
so making 182. 80 000 a year by the way
yeah it gives me so much hope for the
future generation i feel like it's often
so easy to dog on the younger kids
coming up and say they're irresponsible
but from what we're seeing walking
through this lobby and coming onto the
show it's like man we are seeing some
incredible people in their 20s which is
just super inspiring yeah yeah i mean
the 20s got their group too but
everybody's got their group right but
this bunch but there's a bunch of good
ones in this batch
it really is and we're running into them
everywhere we go and
being very smart very wise um very
careful
the the this particular z generation is
they're a little more serious
there's not a lot of flower children
among them well they've been through a
lot you know they've seen a lot of
financial struggle they've seen a
pandemic a lot of them are realizing you
gotta get on your stuff now
yeah i guess i feel like most of us have
been through some stuff but this this
generation like they're they're on it
they're game on i like them i love it
good bunch